well the biggest misconception is that
science has ever settled I think the
public has that to their to their you
know uh to their dismay because
believing that science is settled is
antithetical to science think about it
Dave if if uh Galileo came along and
said well Aristotle was a scientist he's
very smart uh I'll just accept that
there are only four elements instead of
you know 114 or that heavy Things Fall
faster than light things all these
things he could have verified by the way
but he didn't actually go out and do
that uh but Galilee would never have
come up with the laws of initial laws of
Relativity same with Newton Einstein
because well Newton is a genius I can't
outdo Newton as he often looked up to
him so therefore as Richard Feynman the
great Nobel Laureate of the 20th century
said science is the belief in the
ignorance of experts otherwise you'd
have no motivation to ever modify refine
and improve upon who or what came before
you
I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today is a
distinguished professor of physics at
the center for astrophysics and space
Sciences at UC San Diego and author of
the new book Into The Impossible think
like a Nobel Prize winner Brian Keating
finally welcome to the Reuben report
thank you Dave you were my first big
guest on my podcast so it's it's nice to
return the favor I know you've been
looking forward to having a big guest
like me on for a while
I've wanted a man of science on for
quite some time uh no I've wanted to
talk to you for a while on the show
because I think this will be a little
bit different than the shows that that
we normally do but framing one thing
sort of politically just to jump us off
as a man of science and as a man that
just wrote a book about how scientists
approach science what do you make of the
state of science at the moment science
is getting pretty banged up these days
yeah it's it's tough you know I used to
say I enjoy being an astronomer because
there's no Republican asteroids there's
no Democratic comets there's no you know
it's apolitical but it's become
incredibly politicized as you point out
I always point out Dave you know the
word science in Latin I know you're a
scholar so you'll know this word science
means knowledge it doesn't mean wisdom
so to expect wisdom from people that are
knowledge you know junkies Wikipedia has
a lot of knowledge doesn't have any
wisdom you wouldn't want to trust your
dog with it right so I I do believe that
we're living in a fundamentally uh
scientific technological age that kind
of is worshiping scientists way more
than I think we weren't
um as anyone who's ever known uh the
famous joke about scientists how do you
know a scientist is outgoing because he
looks at your shoes when he talks to you
and uh you know it's it's it's part of
the goal this book is to do is to
humanize scientists and to to you know
recognize that we're just human beings
we have no special you know truth claims
or wisdom claims than anyone else
does that sort of Chasm between
knowledge and wisdom sort of capture
exactly the moment we're at in a way
where it's like we hear things every day
in the news okay there's a new study
that says something that tells us
something about knowledge to some degree
but then the wisdom of the policies that
then we are told we have to follow often
seems a little screwy at least in my
humble opinion yeah looking again you
know if you look to somebody uh for
wisdom when you know again looking for
to Wikipedia for wisdom is not going to
be too fruitful uh and yet We crave it
because we worship at the altar of
Science in some way justifiably so it's
led to life you know increases uh child
mortality rates plummeting vaccines and
so forth that are just miraculous and in
any other way would be difficult to
describe it understanding the
composition evolution of the universe
you know to to a fraction of a percent
just astonishing and yet we don't as a
laity as a lay person don't really have
a good understanding of how science
works so as the words of Arthur C Clarke
say any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from Magic and some
say it could be instinctual from a God
and so I think there is a tendency a
desire to worship at the altar of
Science and I think that's misplaced
because we don't elect scientists uh as
a population we elect politicians a
president uh Governors Etc we elect
those people and they want to pass off I
think some of their responsibility to
the scientists who we don't elect and we
wouldn't elect in any other capacity
so last part on this specifically but do
you sense that sort of the reputation
that Science And scientists have gotten
over the last year where it's been so
sort of battered and inconsistent and
wear masks don't wear masks it's the vax
is working it's not working booster
shots the whole thing do you think it
can recover in the next couple years
because right now when they just Trot
out the next study like at this point
I'm just like this is just just more
nonsense I'm not saying I don't believe
that the study was conducted but what it
will always lead to is just like I can't
listen to this stuff anymore well the
biggest misconception is that science
has ever settled I think the public has
that to their to their you know to their
dismay because believing that science is
settled is antithetical to science think
about it Dave if if Galileo came along
and said well Aristotle was a scientist
he's very smart uh I'll just accept that
there are only four elements instead of
you know 114 or that heavy Things Fall
faster than light things all these
things he could have verified fight by
the way but he didn't actually go out
and do that but Galilei would never have
come up with the laws of initial laws of
Relativity same with Newton Einstein
because well Newton is a genius I can't
outdo Newton as he often looked up to
him so therefore as Richard Feynman the
great Nobel Laureate of the 20th century
said science is the belief in the
ignorance of experts otherwise you'd
have no motivation to ever modify refine
and improve upon who or what came before
you so I I view that uh and and if you
went to the to the detriment of Science
and scientists themselves you know often
people say I'm no Einstein I can't
understand it well guess what Dave
Einstein wasn't Einstein you know in the
beginning of his life so I think the
more that we kind of venerate without
explaining how science is actually done
it harms our own practitioners of The
Craft of science that I I am engaged in
yeah and that really actually is what
the book is about because you talk about
things like creativity and human
expression and passion all of these
things that we don't really associate
with scientists and their work
specifically so let's just dive in so
you have nine chapters here each one
going off a different scientist for a
different reason I thought we could just
spend a couple minutes on everybody but
you got to leave some Secrets here
otherwise people won't buy the book so a
couple minutes on everybody I know how
it works chapter one is about Adam Reese
the Stargazer yeah so Adam is a
contemporary of mine he's basically my
age and back in uh I think it was 2005
there was a worldwide competition to
determine uh who is the greatest you
know scientist under the age of 40 and
he and I entered it I came in first as
the most promising scientist of all time
at least of that age and then Adam came
in third uh and so uh later you know six
years later when he won the Nobel Prize
my my older brother Kevin who watches
the show uh he called to report on me
and said Brian you won the battle but
you
you had the temporary reprieve So Adam
is um is an incredibly curious uh
individual he's very young and what is
often said about the Nobel Prize in fact
by Nobel Laureate T.S Eliot who won it
for literature he said the Nobel is a
ticket to your own funeral because no
one ever does it after he wins it and
Adam is a real counter example to that
Canard because he has gone on to you
know Great Heights astronomically and
otherwise uh educational mentorship Etc
I think he best exemplifies the fact
that you know Dave I never thought I
could be a professional astronomer you
know growing up as we did on Long Island
uh you know I I thought like oh
someone's gonna pay me to be an
astronomer like they're going to pay me
to be an ice cream taster or you know or
a wizard or something like that so I
really do look at him as the Fulfillment
of this dream that you can do it uh you
can achieve your your passion but
passion alone is not enough you need to
have insatiable curiosity I say passion
is a spar work but the fuel is actually
curiosity if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about Academia instead of non-stop
yelling check out our Academia playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics check out our
full episode playlist they're all right
over here and to get notified of all
future videos be sure to subscribe and
click the notification Bell